is it that hard to wear a mask
it's not if you've lost a loved one to
covet 19 and understand the gravity of
this pandemic
but for people with no connection to the
coronavirus
it's easier to say that all these health
precautions are over the top
and despite the science
then there are surveys that show men are
less likely to wear masks than women
some claim it robs their manhood
experts put it down to toxic masculinity
[Music]
in the west they said masks don't really
protect you
then they said they do and you've got to
wear them whatever the case
if it means i'm less likely of passing
on something i'll do it
a lot of other men aren't so willing
there are lots of selfish people in this
world
but what about when the masculinity in
question here
is that of the most powerful president
in the world
dw's maria frica has this report
[Music]
on election day the u.s is battling
another surge in coronavirus cases
the number of new daily recorded cases
has been reaching record highs
[Music]
some icu units in the us are already
approaching 90 percent of their capacity
well things are very very bad in the
united states right now we are having
some of the largest outbreaks that we've
had during the entire pandemic
and nine ten months into this pandemic
we are still largely not
quite prepared the u.s doesn't top the
list when it comes to fatalities among
those who tested positive for the
disease
but it's much higher up when it comes to
covert deaths per 100
000 residents so can what went wrong
be linked to the trump administration's
crisis management
critics say the white house hasn't had a
proper sense of emergency
especially at the beginning of the
pandemic
it's going to disappear one day it's
like a miracle it will disappear
and by referring to saskov ii as the
china virus
the u.s president may have been trying
to shift responsibility away from his
government
damage control instead of disease
control
and treatment ideas without any
scientific evidence
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous uh
whether it's ultraviolet or just very
powerful light
and i think you said that hasn't been
checked but you're going to test it
and then i said supposing you brought
the light inside the body you can which
you can do either through the skin or
in some other way and i think you said
you're going to test that too
sounds interesting president trump also
ignored medical advice to wear face
masks for a long time
instead he made fun of his democratic
rival joe biden who wears
masks in public we will beat covert but
you've got to be prepared to deal with
future pandemic biden is soft and weak
and too scared to be proud
he doesn't want to be president let's
face it
but many trump supporters admire the
president's aggressive style
and see him as a model of male dominance
[Music]
he is fearless and he this is why we're
going to vote for him that's
why he's going to have another four more
years because he is not
afraid of the naysayers don't do this
don't do that
critics have pointed to trump's response
to the pandemic
like downplaying its dangers as an
example of stereotypical masculine
behavior
but that may have come at a high price
for the us with his approach potentially
contributing
to more than two hundred and thirty
thousand deaths in the country
jasmine besson casino is a professor of
sociology at montclair state university
why do you believe mass squaring's
become such a gendered
issue especially in the us
it's really interesting to see a virus
become a political issue as well
in our research we found that it's not
just a gendered issue it's also
also a partisan issue for example
democrats in the united states are more
likely than republicans to wear a mask
but it's also a deeply gendered issue
women are more likely to wear masks
and it's not just about straight gender
but it's about gender identity
when we ask men how masculine they are
the ones who say that they are very
masculine
are the ones who really refuse to wear
masks can you tell me what it's got to
do with masculinity i mean
not washing your hands after going to
the bathroom is
just disgusting and irresponsible
it is but we also found that men are
less likely to wear wear masks and also
wash their hands
mask became a symbol of traditional
masculinity
it's about toughness it's about being
resistant to the virus
it's about health and in the united
states especially in in most of the
western world we do define traditional
masculinity through
good health and virility so a virus
can't really get you down or
even if you get the virus virus it won't
do anything to you so our images of
traditional masculinity really are very
harmful here
i guess it doesn't help either when the
president compares manhood with
invincibility
absolutely and traditional masculinity
and ideas
of masculinity are at play there as well
so when we think about like
the american president we had presidents
who were cowboys and rode
uh horses and cleared bush so this is
actually one of these ideas of
that go back to that and this is also
something that really harmed uh female
candidates
uh running for office so it really it
doesn't help that the president is a
part of this as well
but if we just go back to the cowboys
and the pioneers of the united states
taking protective measures is a survival
strategy
yet mask averse men prefer to risk
what death from a virus that expose
their vulnerability
uh prior research actually shows us men
are less likely to go to the doctor
they're less likely to seek a preventive
medicine and even if they have
symptoms they're less likely to ask for
help so
their definition of health is not really
a very healthy one
so similarly we do find that even if
it's
in their best interests and best
interest of their families and children
and communities
they're like less likely to wear masks
also we're a very individualistic
society and idea of wearing a mask is
really going uh against that i wear
a mask to protect my community and other
people and in this case traditional
masculinity is a little bit more
individualistic
exactly all these men are invincible but
they're also
irresponsible i mean does this some have
something to do
with the fact that in many western
nations the individual
is more important than the community you
get very different opinions in china
absolutely i i think individualism is a
big part of this
and i'm not just wearing the mask to
protect myself i am wearing to protect
you and in my community and this really
goes against this ethos of individualism
that
i can be alone and this isn't a
problem of our community that we solve
together but this is something i saw by
myself
okay we've been talking a lot about men
what about the women
who refuse to wear masks i know a few of
them
a few of them are there but most of them
research shows that they tend to be more
republican than men
but also we do see anti-intellectualism
and mistrust of science
among women too we do see that uh some
of them are questioning science and they
don't really believe in the likelihood
that they will get the virus
yes man what what about you on a
personal level
how does it annoy you when you walk down
the street or or or
i don't know wherever you wherever you
go and people aren't wearing masks or
aren't sticking to the rules
i don't go to many places these days
unfortunately
unfortunately i don't go to many places
these days but hashtag stay at home join
me that much i i do find it it's uh
i i enjoy that at least it lets me go
out and it became the new normal for me
and my family and i like
that i like seeing people in my
community wearing the mask
and we hope to beat the virus soon
yes my best and casino thank you very
much for joining us today professor of
sociology
at montclair state university pleasure
talking to you
thank you so much appreciate it
now if you've got any questions on the
coronavirus then feel free to write to
us on our youtube channel
dw science correspondent derek williams
will look into them
what impact on national health will
reopening schools have at this stage of
the pandemic
i've been sitting on this divisive
question for a while
to to watch how things develop as kids
in many countries in the northern
hemisphere including my own
returned to schools if schools can act
as super spreader sites and and with
classrooms being enclosed areas where
lots of kids gather for extended periods
of time
um you'd have expected to see spikes in
cases within societies as a whole
in the few weeks after they reopened a
couple of months ago
but a lot of current data indicates
that didn't happen um numbers of cases
in both the u.s
and europe have of course risen
dramatically since then but many experts
believe
that isn't down to reopen schools but to
other factors
a number of studies from different
countries including ones that
collect extensive contact tracing
information
um they're painting the picture that
although
kids can of course catch the virus and
of course they can give it to others
they don't seem to be driving community
transmission
but instead mostly reflected
especially younger children who appear
to be less likely to infect others
than older kids but all in all
based on what we're seeing so far
clusters seem to develop pretty
rarely in schools that's at least one of
the reasons why the german government
for example
has decided to leave them open even as
spiraling numbers of infections across
the country
have now sent it back into a november
lockdown that's
closed many businesses um how
long schools will remain open here
though is anyone's guess
as scientists never tire of telling us
we're in a dynamic situation
[Music]
you